both now oh this afternoon let it snow a
fast-moving storm has coated parts of
the valley in the Foothills with winter
weather this is one of many viewer
videos we received mainly from the
Henderson area there you see the
umbrella doing what it can to uh handle
those light flurries there we thank you
for joining us here at noon I'm John
Langley and we're going to start with
this winter weather Andy Yarbrough sent
us this video this again is from The
Anthem Highlands Henderson area and you
can see it's slowly starting to the
rooftop they're going to show you more
of that in a second here because also in
the anthem neighborhood this is in Sun
City Lester davia captured this his
backyard covering his little uh his his
picnic not picnic table his backyard
table there sticking to the ground
though most of the snow we've seen in
the southern Foothills around Black
Mountain but as you'll see with Sherry
in a second it's kind of been in a lot
of other places as well this is a live
look here at this is the downtown area
actually right around the World Market
Center but i-11 in Greenway that has
also been covered in snow there are some
road closures to note this afternoon
right now state route 160 to Pahrump it
is shut down because of hazardous road
conditions the Red Rock loop as well is
closed by wet weather and then up on
Mount Charleston The Visitor Center is
also closed so just some things to
consider here as we deal with this
somewhat unexpected snowfall Sherry I
guess we saw it coming right